you're all ready to make the sandwich of
your dreams
turkey tomato and Swiss on a bed of
romaine lettuce sandwiched between two
slices of sourdough classic but oh no
what
what's this mold but look good news the
molds only on part of the bread so I
could just cut that away and be fine
right there's no such thing as a clean
part of moldy bread that's because mold
is a fungus like mushrooms caps on the
surface are easy enough to spot but
there's a vast network of subterranean
roots called hyphy that you can't see so
let's take another look at that bread of
yours
yeah disgusting well maybe you can just
grab another piece from the same loaf
well that's not such a good idea either
because by the time the mold sprouts its
fuzzy head what you're really seeing is
the reproductive part of the mold called
sporangium each sporangium releases tens
of thousands of spores so even though
you can't see it that entire loaf could
be teeming with fungus but it seems like
such a waste to just throw it out
after all you eat mold on purpose all
the time like the mold that goes into
making cheese soy sauce and even
life-saving antibiotics like penicillin
eating a little bit on your bread can't
be that bad right well ultimately it's a
gamble just like eating a wild mushroom
many are fine but some can be deadly
mold is the same way there are thousands
of different species of mold many of
which are harmless to humans but since
so many types can sprout up on food it's
nearly impossible to know if what you're
eating is safe cladosporium for example
can sometimes trigger allergies but is
generally harmless whereas other molds
like Penicillium crust
produce harmful poisons called
mycotoxins an elderly couple in 2005 for
example was admitted to the hospital
after eating a can of soup contaminated
with this kind of mold they had severe
muscle tremors but eventually recovered
but other molds like Rizzo fast Ilana
fur can have permanent effects and you
might recognize this mold since it
commonly grows on bread blue green with
black splotches and super fuzzy in rare
cases it can prompt a deadly infection
called zygomycosis which causes your
blood to clot and can ultimately starve
your cells of oxygen to the point that
they die and it's not like bacteria
where a little heat will eliminate the
threat because high temperatures won't
break down the mycotoxins and since you
have no clue which one you're about to
put in your mouth
ask yourself well is it really worth the
risk